sixteen players 1874 average rating 30
minutes windmill
round 1 let's get this thing out of here
let's go with d4 and I might want to try
just this ooh
oh oh it could happen it definitely
happened I want to get back on this
diagonal let's get right here watch over
this and still f4 would they really
Castle no light up oh I think it's here
I think it's here it still works
even though there's this it's like a
double minor piece ACK Oh check here han
recapture pawn push followed by mate
that's the threat rook here does that
work maybe maybe not because there's
Queen check they resigned back to
tournament two somebody also has a win
2-1 vai Barry is playing for Team white
here team white and alright fishing pole
definitely strikes again here and it may
strike that might not be the end of it
they may not be the end might still be
around it could happen in a blink in a
blink it could happen
don't give up on it don't you dare give
up on it are they gonna really take the
bait take the 100 you can't go two for
two can you no way it's actually okay to
take the knight there it's defendable
okay that's right away I don't want okay
let's
okay now it's probably not happening so
now let's react to it but they've
invested a lot of time having to think
their way through that one it was a time
burner at the very least it was a time
burner I can't recapture with my night
anymore because of the pin I want to get
my rook here so now I could recapture
with my knight Knight takes Knight and
then I'm on the bishop getting material
and I'm also looking right for that
white King I'm on the bishop rook up and
over maybe this works on the Queen and
the bishop dual-threat no good solution
with check I should have taken there no
no no oh that's a that's well there's no
time ah six and a bunch of two's let's
close out of that tab that was open
there all right the NC strong player is
doing battle let's do this first
ENC i gotta go for this if i oh okay
now we have what okay my opponents
running in Reverse run in reverse and
I'm dropping that pond or am i I can
still go for this idea I'm pretty sure
Oh
f5 is available whoa it's a little bit
scary night here I don't know that I
could really take man I still can't take
it if it plays there this is scary
my bishops gonna be trapped maybe okay I
could do this because I have this block
available let's do this I think there's
gonna be a pawn push or something let's
do this stop that diagonal
to force the situation here back up my
light square bishop where I guess right
here and then back up my bishop I don't
want some like rook sacrifice get that
out of here play my bishop here the
knight is actually close to dead tonight
here I'll still think about this move
first get that Queen out of there and
then take the knight or maybe just push
yeah actually I like pushing first
looking for this move and then take the
knight I'm ready to close the door on
this fish up there down there less than
10 and take here and then here and then
push my pond and then I want my queen to
get to this square you have some
exchanges coming up Queen here works out
well hitting my pawn and Bishop so
thankfully time is on my side time is
there okay they're down on time back to
tournament twelve six six two to less
than 25 ticks remaining double those
points and alright do I have to keep
saying I have to keep saying it you just
know it so the silent the silent but
deadly combo silent but deadly I'm okay
with doubled pawns I could play on the G
file and it work well with this Bishop
maybe so pressure on this there's some
pawn moves available but let's do this
Knight takes here there's this pin but I
have this pawn around Queen here might
be pretty good let's do this hitting the
Queen in the night Queen's are coming
off the board but I still feel like
there could be an attack against the
King I think they're missing that I have
lateral whoa they're not missing
anything got chicks up their sleeve they
got tricks up their sleeve okay
hang on here I think it's okay maybe I
could have gotten away with taking the
night but I don't want to do it just yet
maybe look here first actually now I'm
gonna do this because now threatening to
take tonight I could follow up with
Queen here and everything's protected
let's try it made threats maybe the
knight is there to watch over it take
with the pond closes this but I'm gonna
get on this diagonal maybe here was
better let's come over here time
situation is pretty tight pretty tight
time situation Bishop here or here pin
the night they're uh they're tuned up a
lot of time now okay my bishop is here
to stay
cannot be dislodged I'd love to have my
king right here let's go King should
have grabbed that pond to remove that
let's go right here take that night the
night whoa okay that's not working
really okay there they resign back to
turn what they were down that time to 26
all right let's go let's roll here f4
I'm gonna follow up with the pin on b5
okay if takes in the knight c6 I was
gonna throw in a pin
gotta watch out for ya that is a pain
actually this is not the first time I've
run into this how many times am I gonna
do this okay I'm on that Bishop oh I'm
dead I just dropped a piece but you can
do it you could do it can you can you
really do it man that's a bad one
I'm down a full piece I got to take with
my king otherwise there's Forks uh run
away King okay you know what I'm looking
for
you know exactly what I'm looking for
right now time burners there's not an
there's look at the clock situation
though there's nothing you can't come
back from this you can't come back from
this can you give a check grab a pawn
actually I don't want to grab that pawn
just yet get there whoa whoa those pawns
keep pushing oh can I get can I get
behind here somehow is there rip gonna
take no way you can't come back from
this can you you can't come back from
this can you no you can't
that Bishop is in a wonderful spot all
they have to do is keep pushing that
pawn I don't have a good solution no
good solution time burners is the only
solution time burners time burners time
burners more time burners I need more
time burners more time burners where are
they
yes I got I was holding my breath oh man
I should not have won that there's no
way you should be winning those games oh
if you're new to the stream I don't know
there's still zero explanation for it
but it happens David Blaine mode right
there just dive right into that tank and
hold your breath Oh hold your breath
it's gonna be okay disaster one day I'm
gonna figure out how not to lose a piece
in that variation cuz it's not the first
time it's happened ah okay and this guy
is prepared to give me a beating this
guy if you give him a minor piece plus
it's gonna have some fun he's definitely
gonna have some fun if you give them a
minor piece without a doubt okay I need
to get here you know you want to get
here and you want to get here next hit
that Queen and get to F for your Queen
to g5 and have some fun throw an H 5 the
Queen might be trapped may be tricky
Knights
beware of the tricky Knights I don't
have to react to that or do I
I don't okay I'm just gonna come all the
way back I don't know I like my knight
right here right here is exactly where
he wants to be and that Knight is gonna
kill me so I better defend f5 oh it's
coming here okay what's happening here
my bishops gonna get hit the upper okay
I gotta watch out for that rook he's
brutal my knight would uh whoa let's do
this before this opens up it's capture
first then play here then place five oh
man this is a disaster isn't it
I need a Queen trade to help out with
some defense come on defend defend
defend command Knight you know you want
to defend come over here to defend these
squares
get out of there Knight oh this pawn
could fall or can it move move move move
move okay defend what's the clock
situation these pawns finally they could
get working get working
let's take care
keep going pawns right here right here I
got it I'm controlling the Queen square
they missed it with the Czech promote
everything is okay when you promote is
it may its mate back to tournament oh
man
okay there's no I shouldn't have entered
meeting there's I don't like when
there's too few people I thought there'd
be more joining I am kind of those
chickens too fast though too fast okay
let's go let's go let's go let's go
in anticipation of d5 that's why I did
that a4 movin let's start f4 I'd have to
worry about d5 now that the queen is on
that c7 square clean here Queen at you
one Queen h4
not so fast actually okay let's do this
there's no pawn push otherwise I get the
Queen I've seen that happen before
Bishop out Queen here okay let's do this
it's weasel around with my knight still
looking for something fancy here
Knight g3 Knight age five I don't have
to react to an age six move I might want
to just take that pawn if they do that
let's take first open up the a file then
back up defense e2 I thought I would
have this but now that it's defended I
don't I want to get an f6 and I could
this pawn can't move it's pinned f6 is
brutal let's um get this now let's do
this first
uh-oh mate in one two three threat one
two three
g4 first I'm gonna try and mask it as
best I can
right here mate threat Bishop takes
Bishop I have a mate threat Queen h6
rook here Queen takes pawn be aware of
this idea sneaky sneaky sneaky Queen sac
line back to tournament 56 30 18 okay
this guy is 23 27 we could get
or did we already get paired up maybe
maybe maybe maybe okay I'm not really a
big fan of this let's try this
bloomenfeld gambit the Blumenfeld
alright Bishop takes I have a queen
check it's not winning anything though
because there isn't convenient reply
just night out let's try this
get my development in there it's like
Benko dark square bishop whoa okay okay
well oh there's gonna be a queen check
let's come back here okay I'm gonna run
the f8 if there's a check okay there's
no check let's do this that could have
got bad right there what's a queen check
I didn't have a good response so I have
pressure on the I'm the one really down
on time till I don't the Senate open up
maybe I could have had that happen and
it would benefit I want to maybe get rid
of this Knight
what's my queen doing she could do
something else can't she let's come back
home come back home where it's nice and
cozy look for c4 and Knight c5 okay
that's not happening Knight here that
can't be maintained can it oh man okay
let's try this that Knight isn't gonna
bother me so much a real lot it's
definitely gonna bother me
oh he's bothering me Queen here I just
got to go for Queen trade I'm dropping
d6 but I just need to make sure the
Queen's are long gone get out of there
Queen they're not moving they're
cheering up a lot of time there okay and
I'm dropping this I'm dropping
everything Oh dropping everything but
there is no time to convert the point to
convert the material plus there's
another pond that I'm dropping no time
no time back to tournament
seventy two forty thirty sixteen Frank
mr. Frank already I think Frank knows
that the set up that I would normally go
alright he's gonna be well-equipped he
already knows that whoa
I want to do that immediately because I
don't want to deal with Queen sitting on
h4 and I have enough defenders on d5
right there and take this Bishop and
throw a rope right here pile up on that
night let's do this before there's a pin
actually it's probably better I want to
get rid of that Bishop on push is
threatening to win here pawn here pawn
here uh-oh this could be a problem
g4 for the win caught up on time
here we go I have this covered with my
knight maybe just gonna cash in take one
piece down we'll take one pawn down okay
développé drop that B to pawn who cares
about it who cares about the B to pond
get active with your hooks on the knight
on the Queen get rid of the knight
watch out for the forks get rid of that
night why'd I have to allow this happen
okay there's some checks here not the
greatest thing to really be allowing but
it's okay just get rid of the tricky guy
get rid of that tricky guy time time
time time time time back to chairman
okay I got nine in seven games in for
the others nines and sevens rain shadow
let's go with d4 and then this alright
so what is this this is like a French
exchange but with c4 thrown in the mix
let's get some development and I'll take
I'll consider taking on this square
after that guy moves and where right now
when I'm gonna be up upon and I'll try
to hang on to it make things
inconvenient Knight is looking for this
square I might want to just give up my
night just to get the light square
bishop or the bishop pair let's open it
up that's exactly what you should be
doing if you have the bishop pair open
shop here I will go for Queen trade
maybe I shouldn't have gone flat maybe I
should've brought my queen out here okay
bishop pair Bishop pair is throwing a
check the king is having to run to the
corner now flight Square and watch over
Knight g5 f5 do this I could back up and
defend my rook King position first
alright let's come back now bishop pair
open position get your king working ok
I'm dropping one of my bishops but I'm
ok with that
this pond King position King position
King position King position Pacman mode
get those pawns get those pawns watch
out for sneaky tricks hang on there was
a sneaky trick right around the corner
right there if I take that pawn watch
out watch out for sneaks watch out for
the sneakiness ok I'm gonna take that
back up and get this guy rolling get
going get going
pawn push pawns on light bishop on dark
um sneaky night I gotta go fast
who cares about trying to win this you
got to play with the clock here Clark
Clark I get that night well this is just
okay I'm dropping a bishop and stuff
down on time 110 70 windmill is in
second okay let's roll let's roll let's
go let's go let's go oh no no no no
let's go advanced French because this
could I'm gonna go with this I'm not
gonna recapture that mmm yeah I'm not
gonna recapture this pawn I'm just gonna
play aids for you to preserve my bishop
get Mike no I almost just did something
weird right there my mouse got stuck 92
I hear back up that bishop I have this
supported enough h4 h5 that I didn't
want a castle cuz I have some ideas of
my real coming to life over here let's
take let's push here the knight has to
go somewhere and this Queen is I think
close to dead very very close to dead
she's in big trouble I think I think the
queen is in big trouble just to go here
or something
yeah Bishop here I drop tonight I'm
gonna go with this so I could get Bishop
here and then I think the queen is in
some trouble or even Knight back here
it's maybe best okay let's do this I
want to get this pawn back what am I
really getting it back no no I'm
dropping stuff but but but can I get
this in somehow maybe f4 now over rook
okay
all right the coast is clear we're even
on time and let's just take this pond
and then Bishop here is a threat
okay there's there was a lot of tempo on
that Queen in this game this pond could
fall this pond could fall it's finally
Castle get my other rook here but no
watch over my rook I'm gonna take with
check and then play here all right where
is the mate where is that mean okay
let's do this
careful whoa there might be like a queen
feels like I could do this even though
I'm it's pinned there down on time 130
72-68 this is not there's definitely
more competitive tournaments so if
you're just watching this for the first
time there is not always this type of a
separation so it's much much closer
there just isn't so many players in this
one so 25 players currently seven
minutes in change here what's the scoop
here what is that scoop I'm not getting
paired up so what do you do when you're
not paired up you go to see what other
games are going on like this guy right
here who is in second he is the one
that's behind me okay and I just got
paired up let's double the points
develop with the tempo now push this
pawn up this is clean swing over there
no I can't do that right away so okay
well this is just um Sicilian my Knights
ready to move and hit that bishop I need
more development because the knight here
could happen really really soon be aware
of that on the white side of the open
Sicilian Knight d5 or even Knight f5
moves this 95 being the more common very
good
Pond sacks or peace sacrifices excuse me
I want to push here okay now we're gonna
have the position open up and I'll
recapture with my night I like my queen
right here and maybe I want to get to
this square with my knight now let's go
here because I could change the
structure now isolated pond and let's
get this Bishop off I want to just
target this guy pile up right here and
then Queen here now Queen here flight
square is what I need g6 I think rookie
4 is needed but then I have this pawn
push and there's no need to do it right
away I'll guess there is F 4 maybe I
want to do a 4 I like this better
this is better be 4 right away actually
I could do this there's no hurry with
this pawn push I don't think that Queen
needs to get out of there I don't like
her there she needs to go somewhere else
uh what am i doing
my king my queen okay what's the clock
situation okay I have an idea
rook here just get these Queens off my
queen wants to be on f6 okay she's happy
now let's get this over here watch out
for Queen coming here get out of there
rook takes now I have it covered oh the
queen is dead and now this is uh okay
where's the mate where's the mate
where's the mate where's the main that's
me back to tournament 150 the King was
getting the little nuts right there a
little nutty nutty nutty professor the
nutty King the nutty King right there
alright let's go with this so it's a
little bit quiet the Queen could be
trapped if if she stuck around there and
didn't play h6 queenside castle throw
the H pawn exchange the dark squared
Bishop and then it's much easier to
attack that King
upon an F okay so there's some lateral
defense now for black
but-but-but-but this pawn is a weak link
to be - it's also pinned not gonna be
taken with check and I might want to
just go for a queen trade or not oh
let's come here rook check
let's throw on this check and then
another check right here and then rook
right here King has to take get on the
open file look at the time whoa I better
start moving
let's go King let's go King throw these
pawns up composition whoa this is a one
King and pawn endgame these guys can't
be caught it's easier to play out this
King and pawn endgame these guys can't
create a passed pawn okay they can't
move now let's do this and then this and
then this
push push your pawns push your pawns no
stalemates don't allow it back up watch
out for that stealing came here clean to
b7 and that's it back to chairman
two minutes and change all right mr.
mathil graph Oh watch out for Queen c7
that's the anti fishing pole that was
sniffed right out white was having none
of that
they've been tuned into the stream
they're like yeah
now what Bishop f4 show me that's the
show me move
show me the fishing pole they said with
Bishop f4 show me that fishing pole this
is a really solid set up by white this
is really solid it's tough to break down
let's get rid of the lights grab bishops
the Knights do not move like that
Cleon here okay let's just be no Queen
here drops pieces don't don't drop
pieces oh they could have taken that
they had a brain cramp on that one I
think easy to do it's easy to get brain
cramps in these uh bullet games
let's go night you know you're home get
to your home Oh Adam Sandler Adam
Sandler I tell you are you - good you -
good for that home checks grab on b2
maybe okay let's just get a flight
square not the best flight square all
right
tied up timewise but but but but what
checks
where we at watch out for the tricky
Forks around every corner on the Queen
back rank mater's defend that night do
not move the knight don't move that
night oh oh okay victory lane run pawn
run pawn run pawn and then a meetin -
two down on time just in the nick of
time ten seconds remaining I am
not going to get paired up or I am could
you sneak one more win in here with that
okay it is a first all right let's close
out of that okay
good games oh I don't like the ones that
turn out to be runaways to be perfectly
honest I like it I like to do so a
little bit of chasing along the way